So a few times in my career I've ended
up in situations where we've had to
pivot and it's mostly based on the
assumptions that we had or the theory
that we were trying to test just
didn't work out for whatever reason.
Or a partner had a different opinion.
So, in one of my tech startups we did
a technical demo that failed and so
we pivoted into a new
technical direction.
Based on the technology we had
which also didn't work out
the way we had anticipated.
So we pivoted again and
ended up acquiring a small company in
business and trying to work that into
our core business which turned
out not to be lucrative so
that changed the conditions upon
which we were operating our business.
So we pivoted again into
a completely different category of
technology business while still
trying to leverage that initial
seed of technology that we had.
The perception for
me was we were running amok,
we were just like wildly thrashing
around and it wasn't acceptable.
So, at that point I stepped back
personally and just sort of took stock
of what we had and what I believed in at
that point, went back to my core values.
And went back to our first idea and
decided on a reimplementation of that.
And that actually gave the company
the engineering direction
it needed to launch a product.
It only took six years.